the despicable Me movies are always
stuffed with stacks of pop-culture
references and easter eggs that can be
lots of fun for fans to uncover
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and I've scoured Despicable Me 3 for
Easter eggs funny references plus other
cool things you might have missed and
I'm going to be revealing all of them in
this video and I've also got a bunch of
cool merchandise in the movie to give
away so make sure you subscribe and turn
on your notifications and answer the
question I'll be asking later in the
video a quick reminder also that there
are some spoilers in this video so take
care if you haven't seen the movie yet
let's kick off with a very cool Easter
Egg two illuminations next animated
movie How the Grinch Stole Christmas
which stars Benedict Cumberbatch in the
title role you can spot the grouchy
Grinch character from the movie and book
of the same name by dr. Seuss on
Margot's t-shirt in Despicable Me 3 but
this isn't the first time this
illumination has featured one of their
upcoming films in this way if you look
back at the first Despicable Me movie
which was released in 2010 you'll see
that Margo wore a t-shirt with a picture
of the Lorax on it and that character
popped up in his own movie two years
later as mrs. unicorn obsession
continues in Despicable Me 3 and there's
a funny callback to the unicorn toy from
the funfair in the first movie that GRU
eventually went for her in Despicable Me
3
Agnes wanders into the Tipsy Unicorn bar
and Freedonia where she meets a
bartender who apparently has a real
unicorn horn
and after she grills him about the
unicorn she demands to know if it was
fluffy and he replies with the same
words that Agnes said in the first movie
it was so fluffy I thought I was going
to die
[Music]
you saw for real like it was so fluffy
regarde villain-con the supervillain
convention for would-be masterminds and
criminals that first appeared in the
minions movie gets a shout-out in
Despicable Me 3 viral post on the wall
during the shot with two minions Bruges
residents mad scientist dr. Nefario has
appeared in all the despicable Me movies
so far including a small cameo in the
minions movie where a young Nefario
showcased his freeze ray to a young guru
and his mother at villain-con in the
third Despicable Me movies oh we
discovered that dr. Nefario had
accidentally frozen himself in carbonite
which is an obvious hat tip to Han Solo
in Star Wars The Empire Strikes Back
Despicable Me 3 introduces a brand new
minion called mell who becomes the
leader of the banana loving
mischief-makers given that mal is the
new top minion in town it seems totally
fitting that he was named after Chris
Miller Dondre the big boss and founder
of illumination studios and notice how
when the minions go to prison Mel also
literally gets number one billing with
zero zero one on his prison uniform to
indicate that he's the head minion and
Mel is not only named after elimination
boss Melly Dondre but Mel's hairstyle is
also modeled after Mela donned rezone
her line in fact Mel's whole design is
based on a birthday card drawing that
co-director Erik Yeon did years ago of
Melandri as a minion Mellors of course
responsible for the minion rebellion
against GRU but before that he played a
hilarious montage of photos that the
minions put together to try and convince
GRU that being bad is so much more fun
than being good and in one of those
shots we can see GRU stealing a rare
artifact that looks a lot like the
golden idol that Indiana Jones stole at
the beginning of Raiders of the Lost Ark
after almost all the minions leave GRU
and company traveled to Freedonia to
meet his twin brother drew although
Fredonia is a fictitious place it's
actually a real word that's originated
just after the American Revolution and
later became popularized in the Marx
Brothers comic movies duk-soo
about a small country called Fredonia in
Despicable Me 3 Fredonia is hilariously
overrun with pigs the police ride on
pigs rather than horses one of the
license plates reads free Pig and the
ceiling in the entrance hall to Drew's
lavish mansion is as Lucy points out
like the Sistine Chapel with pigs pigs
are also incorporated into almost
everything in Freedonia there's a cheese
invaders arcade game in the in a Pigman
foosball game hogs soda and frito Cola
adverts and does that map of Freedonia
suggests the island has even shaped a
bit like a pig back at Drew's mansion
drew introduces GRU to his lair which is
full of statues of past villains from
their family and as they walk past a
gunslinger if you look carefully in the
next shot you can just make out the name
at the face of the statue which is
Grudge cassidy for reference to Butch
Cassidy the real-life Wild West train
and bank robber and if we look at the
rest of the villains in this Hall of
infamy could that be a groove urchin of
Hannibal Lecter over here this clown
looking groom might be a nod to the
infamous clam penny wise from the
Stephen King novel it and its upcoming
big-screen adaptation and next to him
that looks a bit like Igor the classic
hunchback assistant to Frankenstein or
Count Dracula and if that is Igor it
might also be a little tie-in or
reference to universals dark universe as
universal is the parent company of
illumination who developed the
despicable me franchise grew and drew or
of course opposites of sorts and the
Despicable Me 3 filmmakers have
described drew as the yin to groove yang
and on this theme the animators have
cleverly snuck in a variety of yin and
yang symbolism into several scenes
involving GRU and drew first of all the
logo on the side of Drew's despicable is
a riff on the classic yin-yang symbol
and notice how the logo shows up again
on Drew's coffee mug over here ruined
Drew's costumes are also black and white
the same colors that make up the
yin-yang symbol and later when GRU and
drew are up on the side of brats
fortress they roll up into a ball that
forms the yin-yang symbol thanks to
their black and white costumes
later after the brothers get inside
brats fortress drew makes a sly
reference to one of my favorite comedy
shows Steve Carell who voices GRU
drew is probably still best known for
his portrayal of Michael Scott in the
sitcom The Office in Despicable Me 3
after breaking into Bratz Laird drew
says he's feeling queasy and that he
shouldn't have eaten that pot pie this
is a knowing callback to the season 5
finale of The Office where the whole
office played an elaborate ruse on
Michael so they could go home early
where Michael fell asleep after eating a
family-sized pot pie phallus or brat is
of course the new villain for Despicable
Me 3 and thanks to his obsession with
his former fame as a 1980s child star
and his cancelled TV show evil brat he
brings a large amount of eighties
references to the movie 80s music runs
throughout the whole film and I
particularly liked brats homage to
Michael Jackson's moonwalking while
Jackson's 1987 hit fad was playing brat
also makes a clever 80s Hollywood
reference when he unleashes his evil
army of Bratz dolls who he calls the
brat pack the brat pack spelled with a
single T was a term first used in the
1980s to describe a group of
up-and-coming actors who often work
together including Emilio Estevez Molly
Ringwald and Ally Sheedy at one point
brass also says I love it when a plan
comes together which is a nice reference
to Hannibal's famous catchphrase in the
1980s TV series the a-team the Giants
Dumont diamonds that brat steals at
beginning of the movie is a riff on the
Pink Panther diamond from the 1963 movie
which starred Peter Sellers Peter
Sellers physical comedy in his portrayal
of Inspector Clouseau in the Pink
Panther movies has also been a big
influence on all the despicable Me
movies according to the franchise's film
makers and you can certainly see they've
drawn inspiration from the style of the
Pink Panther films for this movie's
closing credits the fart gun from
Despicable Me 1 & 2 makes a brief
appearance during the opening
illumination title when one of the
minions barges in and uses a gun to
blast the others the Brad and Gary ice
cream that appears in Despicable Me 3
seems like a funny pun on the famous ice
cream brand Ben & Jerry's but it's also
an easter egg too illuminations short
film Brad and Gary which was directed by
Despicable Me 3 director Pierre coffin
who also voiced the character of Brad in
that short
film and is of course the voice of the
minions as well illuminations previous
movie Sync gets a fairly obvious
shout-out when the minions run into a
recording studio where a musical talent
show called sing is being filmed and on
the way into the show they also run past
some sing billboards outside inside the
studio the minions put on a pretty
spectacular performance with their own
interpretation and minionese of the
modern major-general song from the
Gilbert and Sullivan comic opera the
Pirates of Penzance the minions dance
routine during the song also made me
think back to the wonderful sausage
factory seen in illuminations the secret
life of pets both of which were partly
inspired by the renowned musical
choreography of Busby Berkeley later
during the scenes were brats giant robot
is terrorizing Hollywood you can see
billboards advertising and onions movie
now given that one of the ads for the
film says coming soon and the fact that
its title sounds rather like a play on
the word minions I think this is a
clever tease to the minions to movie
coming in 2020 another Hollywood
billboard was for fast car driver 12 a
bit of a joke at the long-running fast
and furious franchise which is owned by
illuminations parent company Universal I
also chuckled at the Giganotosaurus
wrecks billboard clearly a wordplay
combination of the two dinosaurs
Giganotosaurus and Tyrannosaurus Rex
both of which are part of another
current Universal Studios movie
franchise Jurassic world the billboard
Easter eggs for a fun way for
illumination to reference franchises
owned by their parent company Universal
but I think they may have also enjoyed
poking fun at one of their major
animation rivals Pixar during the
underwater scene at the beginning of the
movie when a pair of clownfish suddenly
appear out of nowhere GRU Lucy and the
minions blast past the clownfish on
their way to stop Balthazar Bratz for
stealing the dumont diamond the moment
does feel a bit on the nose and perhaps
a little Joker Pixar's Finding Nemo and
finding dory
so which Easter egg and Despicable Me 3
did you like the best and were there any
I missed and if there's another sequel
what would you like to see happen in
Despicable Me 4 for a chance to win this
awesome Despicable Me 3 merchandise be
sure to subscribe and leave a comment
about the movie and all
answer the following question in
Despicable Me 3 what substance was dr.
Nefario accidentally frozen in make sure
you turn on your notifications to get
all my new animation and easter egg
videos where i'll be announcing the
winners of the giveaway and let me know
what movie Easter eggs you'd like me to
do in a future video if you enjoyed this
I really appreciate you hitting that
thumbs up button and check out some more
of my videos right here congratulations
to the winner of my Beauty and the Beast
giveaway who's on the screen now if
that's you send me a message on youtube
or via my email on my about page so I
can get your details to send you the
prize thanks for watching and see you
next time
yippee game movie lovers